if you gaze into the abyss long enough
you see the light not the darkness
I'm betting my life on it bring it on
the adventure along the Route man
and I would say
where's that adventure to be found
you don't want someone else's fate man
your Fate's enough and your adventure is
enough it's plenty it's more than you
can ever fully realize and so that's
also part of the reason that we all
believe that the individual has some
intrinsic dignity it's don't be so sure
that your position and your room is so
damn trivial it might be your attitude
towards it that's trivial and if you're
in Dire Straits and dire circumstances
just look at how much opportunity you
have to make things better
[Music]